hello welcome back to Las Vegas now
Harvey Blankfield of Las Vegas real
estate now the sponsors of this segment
he is back to tell us what the future of
real estate looks like
sounds scary so I don't know what the
future of real estate you know uh the
Future Real Estate you know everyone was
panicking about eye buyers you know
those of us in the real estate industry
were kind of panicking and now they've
all kind of gone away oh well not
entirely there's still some out there no
I buyers for anyone who doesn't know
internet buyers I'm going to call them
institutional buyers oh [ __ ] how about
that oh okay okay yes because what they
are is they offer cash they offer
convenience but they do it at a price
they're gonna they're gonna take some of
the profit for themselves that homeowner
would normally be able to keep okay okay
and that's one of the reasons why I kind
of I kind of rail against them a little
bit now I think there's a place for them
if the seller has to sell quick and they
need cash and they want to get out there
is convenience involved but the seller
has to understand they're giving up
money and a lot of money and now the odd
buyers are struggling because they own
properties that they bought and the
market actually went down so now they
can't get their profits so do you see
that we're going from eye buyers to more
traditional methods then yeah I mean
look the tried and true and traditional
methods of real estate work that work
for a long time they'll continue to work
and because our objective is very simple
the use of multiple lists and the use of
marketing the way we do it gets the
seller the most possible profit okay and
that's what we do okay now do you think
real estate
traditional real estate is a good thing
is it a positive overall absolutely I
mean not not that other methods aren't
useful and beneficial and sometime in
the future you'll see eye buyers come
back by the way they're not new I mean
they're just big investors that's all
they really are but they'll come back
again when the market starts to go up in
a rapid pace and they'll see if they
can't skim some profit from sellers
again right they'll be back they will
now what what does this have to do with
the seller though is this expensive for
them or how does that work yeah so a lot
of people would think and assume that
they might be able to save a lot of
money by using an eye buyer but the
truth is they make more money with their
traditional real estate agent and the
cost of a traditional real estate agent
has not changed in a long time the
percentages are relatively the same if
the cost of houses have gone up right so
so sometimes our paychecks are a little
bit higher but the effort is still there
and it's really a percentage of the sale
that we're normally getting there's
other additional fixed costs of course
as well okay well 100
hey can I can I say Happy Thanksgiving
first of all to you guys and to my team
and make sure I got to give a shout to
uh Erica and Carly they made sure that
hey Harvey make sure you mention their
names so I love that now what is what is
what does Thanksgiving look like in in
the blamefield house well first of all
we're doing our team party today right
after this I got to go home and finish
finish putting the food down on the
table and then and then I do all the
cooking I love to cook okay maybe you
can add the little chocolate strawberry
turkeys we just made I'm gonna stop off
and pick up some pretzel sticks right
thank you so much Harvey thank you to
Las Vegas real estate now for sponsoring
this segment all you got to do is call
702-203-1165 or visit
lvrealestateradio.com